[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to reboot
GameSpot's opinion editorial show I'm
your host Mike McCarty here with Jake
Decker how's it going good last week we
put up an episode after that crazy
October 27th we had to pick one game to
focus on and you and I are both big
wolfenstein bands and you know Mario and
assassin's Creed are not going anywhere
so we decide to focus on Wolfenstein 2
and after playing through it we both I
think shared the sentiment that not only
is it a great shooter but it is a great
sequel and pretty much every sense of
the word so that's what we decided to
focus on you had not finished it by the
time I wrote this script I think but you
have now so before we get into the QA
this is our off week episode so we're
gonna get into the questions and
comments would you think of Wolfenstein
2 overall once again all avoid spoilers
but I think after I had played the game
the first thing I did was watch the rest
of reboot because I only added half of
it and yeah the second half but I mean
basically I just mimic everything you
said I think it's a phenomenal sequel I
think the way it builds on what they
created with the first one and the fact
that they didn't try too many different
things they kind of just focused on what
made the first one great and turn
everything else up to 11 in order to
deliver a kick-ass sequel again if you
haven't watched that episode last week
it's mainly spoiler free the second half
does have some minor spoilers if you
want to go in completely fresh but if
you finish the game go watch it it was
episode 17 and this is 17.5 I believe
but as always we're gonna get into some
questions and comments about Bethesda
future of single-player games and how
Wolfenstein and pray and Bethesda games
are selling in general so here's the
first comment on YouTube from the arcane
realm Bethesda has honestly creation
club aside kicked ass this year in their
published titles dept prey dishonor
death of the outsider the evil within -
and Wolfenstein - are fantastic games
and they're all single-player only with
no microtransactions to boot i heavily
agree with that I think Bethesda as a
publisher it's my favorite portfolio I'm
not surprised I wouldn't be surprised to
find out that they're they're definitely
not doing as well as like Activision or
EA because they don't use
microtransactions they they don't just
you know shove in feature for the sake
of it to get multiplayer in and loot
crate's in general you know a we could
throughout this episode like in a few
we're happy to talk more about the
future of single-player games especially
with the closing of e a visceral lately
I think EA is kind of the antithesis to
this you know they said they needed to
pivot the game because it wasn't like in
the they essentially said it wasn't as
much of a games as a service platform
like they're trying to go for with
anthem sounds like that new Star Wars
game that used to be 1313 with Amy
Hennig is now going for that games as a
service kind of model but Bethesda I
agree with the arcane realm Bethesda is
kicking ass in terms of the games I
really like to play this next question
comes from just musicians on YouTube it
says amazing game the only complaint I
have is it is a bit too short but the
characters were amazing and dynamic some
scenes made my jaw drop and the story is
amazing
the main complaint people have about
this game is the PC version has a few
bugs I actually played all on PC I
noticed a lot of people unlike steam and
Twitter have been saying there's a lot
of bugs maybe I just got lucky but I
don't think I had a single bug the
entire game the entire time I played
through it yeah I can't speak to that I
played all on ps4 I didn't have any bugs
at all and I'm running on a 970 so it's
like it's not even like cutting-edge
necessarily so yeah I did hear I did see
a lot of reviews saying that like user
reviews I think it's I don't think I
recalled too many like critical reviews
saying they had bugs I'm not sure but
that is unfortunate people did because I
found this game to be pretty clean in
general I don't think I had any problems
but but yeah to speak this story yeah
again we're not gonna go in spoilers but
there are some scenes that like you know
not to be too hyperbolic but I was
sitting there like holy [ __ ] this is a
really good scene like the comparison to
inglourious basterds holds up even more
with this game and more than the new
order just because there to see there
are two scenes specifically to stand out
in my mind despite the fact there are a
lot of scenes in this game that aren't
just cutscenes I know some people are
criticizing for being like a third of
the game is cutscenes but there are some
that are in game where just gets you so
amped there's one that's super tense and
you can kind of even feel BJ's anger
throughout the scene if you're watching
this you might know what I'm talking
about the audition and just throughout
that whole scene I'm like this this
writing is like top tier like machine
gained a Swedish developer they're
nailing this
these scenes it's like I cannot speak
highly enough of the the writing and the
actual atmosphere and tone that goes
into this game yeah and to sort of speak
to people saying that there's too many
cutscenes not enough gameplay I imagine
a lot of those people didn't actually
finish it or didn't explore the sub and
find out that there's those enigma codes
which allow you to return to levels in
assassinate different targets there's
like an easily over a dozen of them so
the gameplay is there like story driven
gameplay sure you only get six hours but
there's also like three almost four
hours of fantastic cutscenes an
excellent story so I that complaint is
just dumb in my opinion like sorry if
anyone feels that way in the comments
when I'm just gonna say I think that is
dumb like you clearly didn't give the
game to the end or explore everything it
has to offer
yeah and then just musician was also
saying the game's a bit short if you go
through guns blazing the easiest
difficulty I can see you finishing in
maybe like seven or eight hours I think
it took me ten and I was shooting most
people because I recently played death
of the outsider and I was doing stealth
through that but yet I thought it was
perfect length and it was interesting I
think we've mentioned a reboot before
but when we interviewed Harvey Smith for
that arcane series we did speaking of if
you're watching this and you're
interested in Bethesda's games like the
arcane realm was you should go watch
this we didn't know enough a series on
arcane and dishonored and it's really
good but Harvey Smith was saying
actually based on a lot of feedback and
Harvey Smith has been making games back
since like Deus Ex the original one in
the 90s he's been around for a while
knows what he's doing he was saying
based on focus testing and stuff and
just like general sentiment after
dishonor to people actually majority
people like when games are shorter now
like Dishonored 2 was like 18 hours that
game was long for that kind of game
where you're taking a time exploring
thing death of the outsider was perfect
length it was lean like uncharted lost
legacy hell-blade I know obviously we're
privileged enough to play a lot of games
so it's nice when we can finish a game
and have it in our back pocket and we've
experienced it but there are a lot of
people like unless of course there are a
lot people that play like four games a
year maybe destiny and Call of Duty or
like FIFA or something that's awesome to
like put the money you want toward the
games you want to play but I personally
think that if a game is better off for
having ended at a certain spot than do
it
it's like like season seven in the
office it should have ended there yeah
they but they added another few hours to
it especially especially Wolfenstein I
think that is so like very well paced
yeah
all right like I don't want to be like
waiting three hours
I don't play through a three-hour
gameplay segment just to get to the next
cutscene yeah yeah but if I'm satisfied
I don't want to keep playing for another
four hours and feeling it's not even a
matter of like my money's worth because
I think that's a whole separate
conversation and I firmly do not believe
that if you I pay $60 I expect 12 hours
like that's so that's such a dated way
to look at games because Wolfenstein
feels great it's written well it like
it's from it's memorable in so many ways
it's presented well it's just overall
the pacing is great like I I don't go
into a game into games anymore and
thinking oh here's $60 I'm expecting X
hours out of this whether I'm having fun
or not if I got an amazing experience
out of six hours like I did in hell
blade as opposed to the experience I got
out of the division which I've been
replaying recently for a future project
like I'm all for that great six our
experience over 60 hours I feel like I
kind of wasted but that's just like it's
up to people to decide what they want
but I think well if I was great like
perfect okay cool last comment that we
picked out this week was from GameSpot
Subaru 1980 said a very good episode
again and very interesting point of view
some publishers have started a war
against story-driven single-player
gaming that's dramatic not Bethesda and
I know machine games do have plans for a
trilogy with Wolfenstein my question is
what if the new Colossus fails just like
pray and evil within two could that mean
the end of an era for Bethesda Softworks
and no sequels for all those great
titles nope they'll release another port
of skyrim and another port of fallout 4
they make so much money off the switch
VR Skyrim that are coming out I would
assume that yeah evil then ii did not
sell well death of the outsider did not
sell well pray did not sell well which
sucks because that's one of my top 5
games this year i think that game is
more important than we're like
letting on that game is like that game
was single-handedly could have brought
back immersive Sims but I just don't
think there was enough marketing around
it if I really push it and I think
people weren't really ready for that
kind of game yeah I I think to do is
question two I like those game I feel
like they're kind of like Rockstar in a
sense right where they have their big
tentpole game GTA and then at least in
theory like this is more so last
generation but they released like GTA 4
and they did a bunch of weird thing
eyeliner which turned out to be
successful like la noir Red Dead
Redemption which was probably kind of a
risk at the time bullies a cult classic
now but at the time yeah so I kind of
think of it like that like sure these
games didn't do well but I think you
know we're gonna get a Skyrim port I
mean there's gonna be a new Elder
Scrolls at some point maybe a long time
from now and I feel like whatever
Bethesda Softworks does would that be
fallout whether that be I think it'd be
like a New Orleans fallout is my call
next like yeah or maybe that like sort
of space RPG has the game that they've
begged and that people have been kind of
like trademarks and stuff yeah I mean
like I think that'll still probably sell
pretty decently yeah I will say I don't
we're definitely I'm worried for arcane
for sure maybe a dishonored three but if
you played Effie outsider I don't know
how they're gonna just like narrative
Lee how do you continue after death the
outsider it's in the title like what
happened the outsider gives you powers I
mean again like I won't spoil that game
but there are a number of ways they
could go but you know RAF colantonio
left arcane and he was one of the like
he of the two-headed dog that was him
and Harvey Smith he's gone now for now
he's taking a break I don't know if he's
gonna be he's probably not to be back at
arcane obviously they have people
talented people like Ricardo Baer there
and everybody that worked on dishonour
to from there
from their office in France but I am a
bit worried especially like you know you
see the trends with loot crate's and
microtransactions and ei closing
visceral who was a great single-player
studio and then you see dead space
eventually devolve into
microtransactions to be kind of
reductive but I think I don't think
we'll see anything more from prey I
would love to see like a shorter DLC
standalone kind of like death the
outsider but I highly doubt we will yeah
but who knows what our Caine's gonna do
next maybe because evil then too didn't
sell well prey didn't sell well
Wolfenstein - I'm curious to see the
numbers I'm sure it's sold better than
both of those may be combined but I
don't think it's gonna it's not gonna be
gangbusters I wouldn't I would think
especially because the time it really is
that it's not really competing with
Mario or Assassin's Creed but again if
you're someone that buys one game in the
fall then probably in a pig Mario or
Assassin's Creed I would imagine unless
you're super in shooters like we are but
- Subaru 1980s point I am worried about
Bethesda's lineup they are my favorite
publisher in terms of what they decide
to fund and you know people we can talk
like I know to more in the UK office
always says like we've had enough of
Skyrim at the same time if that means we
get to see these great creative titles
like that cascading monetary structure
where Skyrim will fund everything else
like that makes a lot of money and I
bring Skyrim to everything keep updating
it keep updating bring doom bring
Wolfenstein to out on other platforms to
keep funding these creative endeavors
because but des des is one of those
publishers that's really pushing this
single player kind of experience that I
think a lot of people that watch reboot
a lot of people that come to GameSpot
and you and I love I am worried about
Bethesda but I think they'll be alright
for a little while yeah this is this is
kind of a little bit out there but I
think not the destiny - story wasn't
good but I feel like you're definitely
giving up something the minute you try
to make a games for service game where
people are sharing a world like like
destiny is like oh you're the Guardian
that saves the world like okay
or the universe whatever but so is every
other person who plays this game so I
think the minute you do that it kind of
it dilutes the single-player and
I really hope things don't come to that
and I think Bethesda is kind of on that
horse of I guess right I don't know how
to say it they're kind of like the
Crusader yeah they're the the what is it
at the forefront at the forefront yeah
that spear head that's what I was trying
to say that's bad it's weird looking at
my top ten games here you can top five
like 75% of them were published by
Bethesda pray definitely outsider
Wolfenstein two of the evil within to
which surprised the hell out of me I
like the first game I didn't love it
this one I love yeah I'm hoping they can
figure something out monetarily
financially because without them like
you look around at other of the other
big huge triple-a publishers Nintendo's
had an amazing year this was the year of
Nintendo for myself but I would love to
see Bethesda work something out so we
don't just have to keep seeing anthems
and destinies and stuff of that serve I
gave a service kind of inclination okay
Jake any other last thoughts about
Wolfenstein - no got nothing else I
don't think we were really set on next
episode we might go back to Assassin's
Creed Mario if there's something to talk
about there Assassin's Creed honestly
I've fallen in love of the South Street
you know I've not been shutting up about
it we covered it you covered it a lot
for GameSpot everybody else was kind of
doing either Mario or Wolfenstein at the
time but I am very surprised with
Assassin's Creed origins and I would
love to try to talk about it more so
maybe I'll talk about that but also we
have like Call of Duty 2 as of this
video we'll have had it for two days and
then on the 12th I believe number 12 we
will have our next full episode up and
Sunday we'll figure out whether we want
to talk about the hell front - maybe if
we have it by then but anyways as always
thank you so much for sending in
questions just musicians the arcane
realm and Subaru 1980 via GameSpot or
YouTube we appreciate that we really
like doing these off week episode it's
the q and A's but yeah we'll be back
next week in a full episode and we're
looking forward to you seeing that until
then have a good week
thank you
[Music]
you